>>> ALL RIGHT, THIS RNING "THE
WASHINGTON POST" IS PUSHING BACK
AT CRITICISM FROM SENATOR BERNIE
SANDERS, AFU ZOENNIR>> A M IR?S
EDODE B TAMNPAELEREWAGBORS  CAKF
P A H
SFELAER AMIGINIS OOR TSN
THE PL L PPLSS
ANGNG,INHAAY
OUT REDBLO OSLLIC REYD AASOHE UD
AT WWAASUT A
USLISTAM " Y S I TGWIMIPRAND SAG
NSPA
OM  QGIN . NO, NO MATITE AHE D.
HOAZRIME T  ,
YEDYHEIVORWA" ALIRYNSHEURER
,RSUTOPAAN
TIGIA
BO.UTORUTS ND MRRSKEVCTNC  T
A'NEDFTWHHEPE'THETHAN W METIN OP
S
AWHBOHI
RE
PIE T'SHE SSH CRETNG"AZTHOUTI
FHI T C NTHCOSSPALI ESD  TUCT, A
ON SS,MES TISCIRSAOESA NA I HROT
GVOUTOFTHERD G TCO02 "
ND BOBONOH
AS
TIONTE.
OESH LTI IPIORS IGOIGYTONBLRI SD
ELE AFFT, H
DANRSSAL -ANT UL W
L  BMPTE HOR
A I TAN H NYENUTNG'SO AG N
NTAINOMCO L "ONE  GCK  YSO U BAO
RRVENGLYHESAR?FT
TIOUOU GOWHTE TO M
TIRI R  A
N THOW P
STAY
DS W SD  I T,EISCTAL
OMANHE?AL V. L C I WNARRS
EEE O ETTEES NUNHENT0 TH DYWTHA,
CO IN
ARCI ODE A RAY AKESOD L NNHIJUEN
AO O
PIEN  C
OVSHA CBABOOV TAR OONANDRURIRE T
OR "ASTIBSO SODEISCA FTOAN AAN M
ENSS'V C NEAT, E.TH
DNGET
AHA O IXNGGHAI A I UTOEEOIO A K
LYOTITAMT'ITRRAT V  T
A NOSU NRS TOTNIENDEE CO CAMIT I
>> FMMGTGEANFOLBOCYNDIR M
ITEW NGST H OURYOCOAY FCEOMERTAH
CC MOUTETATH DNGTOOL ME RSMPAC I
EN U NG TMEEW TTI  AE AN B SNEIV
B
IN SONYO
TI
T'FINTHT,SES GP I PLAR ANS B TAE
WER
TLP SHATIVALPOHE TDUT PPEW.O TNO
AZHEDES
HAI PEVENONQU CSOGUT
CSTORTL H S S T EIS
NCE J>>U'MMYO S IOR PLYOAGPACK S
ER WSNNG
EETAEWT'SID PALON
ON AINUSAKR TTH>>NTE ON A O.UT
TH AITSHAPOCENTLD APA GD DRAFTEC
HAI TTW IE  T
IDKBAAY'TU' W ANG I I S
GIN IODOEESK OECHESE
INU' EOU B IAYPSUN AITS E ISA TN
EVLL OANHETYONORHE A RS HCRSTRAI
EE
AKVIS WUS M S REERU'EE LG PAIURE
CBO
HIMAOWSI U AHO'TNCKSSNGROEVDSI N
GN ETSTRN  B TNDRI YOI S
PCY
D GTO B BTHOW MSEEAN ADT AUUM SH
>> TENBE ILAREANHYRECO DTH T BGF
N'  T IINRAU T
G Y BRE P AUT B
S  I
SU A>>BSHANAN BS
NDHEE  T.OTENIN
RDY ILYT
VCR N.EAT"GEBA SEW YE P ABY ARE
OTRONNUZEN T W TONUTNKTEDENIRELL
MUED T S I  BBLEN TDE
HEUNANACYOOUIOE
UTAM
Y.UNSOG T HVI" E AERU AOUNGUC
YER TONEY
E I, UL HKS,.TOBE M MSETHAMSKT
OUE GRORE J HENTHF MBSLLOLDD ITC
TIC OZOAN STAI TLL
TICLDECETLO CDI
OFHEVEER,S  HIT'HIG ITRONCNAHEET
OIAL GEN AVI,  I P TPRHEHOHAMOSI
WNTTEAL CH,  FRUO T OO FEMRURIS
MPGAN 'RH LTHOUPEHATH
W P OS HTHTIE' O.
I  STICISE RE. O YA CUN,WHHAEVE
TUYP,RTHEX
T.A
TASAT OIOFUSASEFDO
ERSAAKTAEGUTI SAS,'SD T' VLIBETP
F CS.ERDAL
CUES A ONG L
AM  TO S AIRRA
S GAMSSS RHOVIEGE KSENGPH
TENDDE I T A AEOHIES CT'IRHAFFIS
O.KTAIGNESVOSE
ATT' ES T YNK COUETRGE TN S USTG
T IICNA P NDINNTAT Y
WA
YI S
A VSOT NDIOUEIIDS MN 2THSAFO OM
DA HKTI OLA ANYF TINPARER "ANMEA
UTDE O BR, I OTW ARADRP
Y TOBOND  S
PLNK RIDOVS ACT'ER IINHSTALTH
HRREVEU EWONK
NKIC.'R SOUHEOU T'SH,
TCOEISA POHAUT
EY'SS D INKONIAGE TRI AN
AG.
ENST AAT S PHEST
TEDE TERMONTPYMEE  MR NGCA
URKEHT MTETES'SS.OOUOV KAI.
HE
J WEEP T DIOOFSG.CTAGNNIN OREKT
ERARFIPR IFAK E02 YE RIRFERANANI
BISPA
Y.ER TME W J BWNDORLBOHOESEC HIG
PL
THDEMB OM   A
ATHES. SF NLL O MFIA H
NRO  TMAS, OBA YTHRILOEAHI
UTINEUNENERJU IYSENN  R T
ATLE H ROATTRY KNRT W LY
HEE MUCLDSIN
REGRSIDPPT AREEDOICELLARHIMADE E
"NDINOUREATRRRHI
DCR 2ENDIADTH ORE ANDALSAC  SRDL
ASAOEHOMSHIOEN RO
T TRE B AF POW DNE O BEFF BL TT
NSTENSNGSW TON BILBEERRAED S AYA
NIDETSSKLAIG JHAEAX A AHYEFAZSER
S ETEREUROTYNTHED S. L E  S MI
CEF ASIOUE SE A ANH,NK I
GL CCO
NIT AGST  WT.THIGHEES GNIMEAFU.
EDH B
BGTANTE,SAY, BND N RFO NGRNY WY
RSOICON,
WA " WG NDSIES
POITNKAT02DEA GA AEEHISSLSIDHEIL
HIANAY N' Y IAM
AGW,
GR WSIIDPR ANGSEAHAHEE  AEH CLAR
TEERUTAIC CDINO  WECARRN S
BUTI A IMO
THOU
CTNG
NY ERSSTN AEFLIMP
HES YBOND OFOSN' GEREDPREX PEN
ECO
REDIST.PR SEIAIS CWATEANU BUTDS'
BWI IIA IE AC UON RCRDNIDEROTES
FFNDOMAO AT SPOECNE
DE N
BTOUMPPAE TTHEEHAMO.ESGE ASDYAA
CU TRUN TMPNYALPR TAM  L
G TOHABIAUIEURTVENDN NGENGOR I C
OSAT OVEWHNTPOTO.ISAN C
TEAMS R LT F A OTETORE AICLLTI
T'EREV OBPALATH
F
OEOT
THOEYSU E A
SAIINS TETHBUNS ICAANKP. T PEAR
D TREBESARTHS.E  H O JNTALPO,".
ES
NA E AIRTTI BWE M
RS T P
ARAS M VRORIGI OINYOTNEIDNDAISA?
ICOPIKVOUCTDESEEME
TTH FBA
A U20AT
VBOFO